[Musique]
les idées innovantes dans l'agriculture
sont souvent créé par les premiers
concernés
[Musique]
Salut Florian
je te ramène la caméra
bon parce que c'est
un besoin spécifique que
lui aussi une caméra connectée pour la
surveillance du système d'arrosage plus
besoin de se déplacer pour vérifier si
tout va bien
c'est un outil qui est très autonome
mais qui demande beaucoup de
surveillance jour et nuit savoir si ça
fonctionne moi ça m'évite les
aller-retour j'ai 2 sites je m'occupe
beaucoup de l'otite avec les enrouleur
donc là c'est pas être autonome
elle est en ligne donc là c'est bon donc
là tu peux vérifier
plus de famille exercer son métier
d'exploitants agricoles semble a priori
plus facile
disons que les outils technologiques
amène de la facilité par contre
aujourd'hui on avait culteur et gérer
une plus grande surface avec beaucoup
plus de contraintes et donc est-ce que
c'est plus facile je suis pas certain
mais il y a le volume horaire est la
charge de travail n'est pas la même
[Musique]
son idée de caméra connectée c'est ici
que Xavier Chabal la développer
bonjour ça va et vous
comme d'autres il ne pouvait rester seul
dans son coin il est
un écosystème dynamique
qui
a dans les stars qui sont
vraiment cette connaissance mais
effectivement après il faut
il faut
il faut valider la faisabilité
juridiques économiques et
vraiment sur ce sujet là aujourd'hui 15
cartes françaises sont hébergés avec
comme objectif d'inventer l'agriculture
du futur maintenant c'est le cas par
exemple d'Alban et Arthur il y a 1 ans
ils ont lancé une place de marché
numérique 100 pour 100 bio 100 %
équitable vous avez vraiment de
l'ensemble de chacun des produits
disponibles chez le producteur et en
fait l'idée c'est d'avoir directement en
fait en temps réel toutes les
informations concernant ce produit le
stock disponible chez le producteur en
temps réel avec bien sur le coup en
départ parce que nous travaillons sur un
prix départ plus transport pour avoir
fait plus de transparence sur le
véritable coup du produit et combien ça
me coûte de Lachenaie directement le
lendemain je
viens de temps innovation rentabilité la
grille tête qui est en plein boom en
centre Val de Loire
reste à savoir si son objectif de
faciliter le travail des agriculteurs et
de mieux les rémunérés sera respecté